merci d'être avec nous Stéphane de
ruddiller pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu des
bouches-du-roulement du groupe les
républicains on va évidemment parler de
la réforme de traite on l'a vu dans le
journal Emmanuel Macron qui était donc
en déplacement à Rungis hier à l'aube il
a dit on appelait au bon sens des
Français sur la réforme des retraites
c'est de la méthode Coué non je pense
qu'il a il a fondamentalement raison sur
ce point ce que se passe-t-il on a une
évolution démographique avec deux
phénomènes inquiétants je pense qu'on
l'a pas dit assez mais en 1945 quand on
a mis en place le système de répartition
on avait 6 actifs pour un retraité qui
finançait la retraite d'un retraité
aujourd'hui on en est à 1,7 actif des
projections dans 15 ans c'est 1,2 actif
donc a fortiori il y a de moins en moins
d'actifs pour financer notre système de
répartition qui est effectivement
l'héritage du Conseil National de la
Résistance du Front populaire et du
général de Gaulle le deuxième aspect
c'est qu'on a un vieillissement de la
population
pour la première fois depuis le début de
l'humanité on aura cinq générations qui
vont cohabiter en France et dans le
monde entier donc il y aura des dépenses
sociales supplémentaires donc pour
sauvegarder notre système de répartition
on n'a pas d'autres choix que de
travailler plus longtemps j'ajoute un
point quand même qui qui est essentiel
on travaille nous Français 170 heures en
moyenne de mois que nos voisins des pays
européens donc vous voyez bien je sais
que c'est une c'est une réforme
difficile à comprendre pour les Français
mais si on a moins d'actifs ça veut dire
a fortiori moins de cotisants et
derrière c'est le péril de notre système
de répartition c'est à dire la baisse
des pensions il faut l'éviter à tout
prix de compréhension un problème
d'acceptation est-ce qu'il y a eu un
problème de méthode un problème de
pédagogie
il y a une certaine forme d'illisibilité
effectivement de la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron
s'agissant des finances publiques ou des
dépenses sociales pourquoi parce qu'on
sort de trois ans où on a lavé
l'impression que l'argent magique
existait on dépensait pour soutenir les
entreprises pour soutenir les commerces
pour le chèque énergie etc etc et c'est
des milliards d'euros qu'on a vu défiler
sous les yeux des Français 600 milliards
de dettes en 5 ans donc les Français ont
du mal à comprendre cette cette
politique parce qu'on se dit mais 18
milliards alors sauf que c'est 18
milliards par an donc cumulé ça peut
très vite faire un déficit structurel
assez important donc effectivement il y
a jamais de bons moments pour cette
réforme de retraite mais la
particulièrement c'est c'est vraiment
une rupture par rapport à en tout cas
les opérations de communication du
gouvernement le texte arrive au Sénat la
semaine prochaine est-ce que vous pensez
que le débat de fond pour faire alors
les sénateurs de gauche disent qu'ils
veulent arriver au vote de l'article 7
mais qu'ils utiliseront tous les moyens
nécessaires pour bloquer le vote de
cette réforme
écoutez le Sénas n'est pas dans son dans
son ADN de faire de l'obstruction
parlementaire quand on regarde ce qui
s'est passé à l'Assemblée nationale deux
articles sur 20 étudiés c'est un peu la
note de survint qu'on pourrait donner
aux députés de la France insoumise c'est
de l'irresponsabilité ça fragilise notre
démocratie parlementaire nous nous avons
une responsabilité nous sommes quand
vous regardez bien le seul pôle
institutionnel stable de la Cinquième
République regardez l'état de l'exécutif
regardez l'état de l'Assemblée nationale
et il faut que tout le monde prenne ses
responsabilités la majorité sénatoriale
mais aussi l'ensemble des groupes
politiques pour aboutir à un vote de ce
texte finalement pour que on puisse
remettre en fait l'église au centre au
centre du village et évoquer des sujets
qui n'ont pas pu être évoqués à
l'Assemblée nationale ce texte il est il
est imparfait il faut le rendre
tout juste dans certains domaines et
donc pour le rendre plus juste il faut
étudier les amendements il faut qu'ils
soient voté et que le texte final soit
voté et puis c'est aussi un moyen de
dire que le Sénat quand en 2018 on
entendait potentiellement que ça
suppression serait le bienvenu serait la
bienvenue je pense que Emmanuel Macron a
véritablement changé d'avis sur cette
optique au vu de ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale vous allez
apporter quand même des modifications à
ce texte Bruno Retailleau a déjà parlé
de trois modifications pensions de
réversion pour les enfants handicapés en
décalage pour les régimes spéciaux et le
fait que les femmes qui ont eu trois
enfants puissent partir plus tôt est-ce
que ce sont des lignes rouges est-ce que
si ces trois conditions de son pas
remplies le groupe a l'air de votre a
pas
je le pense mais vous savez le
gouvernement est quand même sur ce sujet
ouvert à négociation en tout cas c'est
son état d'esprit je pense qu'il peut
pas rouvrir une crise politique avec
avec les sénateurs au vu au vu du
contexte effectivement il faut modifier
ce texte pour le rendre plus juste plus
équitable je pense notamment aussi à la
pénibilité revenir un peu sur le sur les
carrières longues analyser ce qui s'est
passé à l'Assemblée nationale où il y
avait une forme d'inisibilité à la fin
ou en fonction de l'âge vous partiez à
43 ou 44 ans donc 143 ans pour toutes
les carrières longues c'est
difficilement soutain alors attention
après attention c'est le coût de la
réforme parce que de 18 milliards
d'euros si on passe à 13 puisque à
l'heure actuelle on est à 13 milliards
et qu'on chiffre les amendements qui ont
été déposés à l'Assemblée nationale
certains évoquent déjà 3 milliards
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires il
faut véritablement garder l'esprit le
sens initial de la réforme c'est à dire
l'équilibre en 2030 donc il va falloir
chercher des recettes supplémentaires
pour équilibrer des dépenses nouvelles
qui rendent plus juste et plus
acceptable le projet de référence
mais avec une compensation et des
recettes supplémentaires ça va être la
ligne du Sénat que vous avez trouvé où
cette recette
il y a certaines pistes qui sont
évoquées vous savez la Cour des comptes
par exemple sur en tout cas c'est un
amendement que je porterais mais sur les
retraites extraterritoriales regardez si
la fraude sociale peut être réduite on
parle de 200 millions à 1 milliard
d'euros de retraite indument perçue par
exemple donc il y a des pistes les
amendements arriveront d'ici quelques
quelques jours mais l'idée du Sénat a
toujours été d'équilibrer le système
c'est à dire nouvelle dépense également
nouvelle recette on va continuer
évidemment à parler de ce texte on va à
Marseille où on retrouve les hauts
purgate bonjour Léo merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous président et directeur
éditorial de La Marseillaise et
justement dans vos pages un dossier sur
la retraite par capitalisation
oui un dossier qui explique que ce
finalement cette réforme va déboucher
sur un surcroît de capitalisation parce
que les personnes n'arrivent pas à
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans redoutant de
se retrouver avec des petites pensions
réfléchissent sérieusement à cette
question de la capitalisation et
Monsieur Le Rue dulier fait partie des
rares qui en ont parlé dans un discours
dominant où il est question de sauver le
système de répartition alors est-ce que
Monsieur le rodulier vous avez vendu la
mèche ou est-ce que vous faites un
effort de lucidité supplémentaire sur
vos collègues j'ai pas vendu la messe
non je suis convaincu il faut dire la
vérité aux Français
on a parlé de la démographie
si on ne change pas de paradigme
effectivement si on adopte pas un
système de capitalisation au système de
répartition qu'il faut préserver à tout
prix je crains fort que dans 4 ou 5 ans
on revienne devant les Français en leur
disant c'est plus 64 ans mais ça sera 65
ou 67 ans il faut être lucide et on
ouvrira de nouveau une crise sociale qui
soit peut-être beaucoup plus dur que que
celle-ci donc l'idée étant de d'essayer
de de
j'allais dire de bouger un peu les
lignes du gouvernement en disant il va
falloir dès à présent réfléchir à ce
nouveau paradigme à un système de
capitalisation collectif j'entends bien
pour que tout le monde puisse contribuer
en fonction de cotisation supplémentaire
cotisation qui serait pris sur le
système de de répartition je pense que
c'est logique vous savez il y a déjà de
mémoire 8 millions d'actifs
qui ont un système de capitalisation
facultatif comme vous le dites c'est
3,5 dans le privé et 4 4 5 dans le
public je pense qu'il faut généraliser
ce système et c'est le seul moyen pour
préserver à long terme à mon sens le
système de répartition
vous avez votre réponse
ah oui oui c'est très clair mais un peu
piqué sénateur en lui disant que cette
réponse elle me fait plus penser à
Reagan qu'à de Gaulle mais il va me dire
non parce que vous savez le système de
répartition pour moi c'est la retraite
universelle garantie pour tous qui doit
à la rigueur évoluer en fonction
l'inflation la solidarité
intergénérationnelle n'est pas remise en
cause si on a d'autres un système de
capitalisation l'idée aussi peut-être
derrière et de rendre la liberté sur le
départ en retrait pourquoi pas imaginer
mais ça n'engage que moi un système qui
permettrait en fonction du taux de
cotisation par capitalisation de dire
infinés au vu du montant de la pension
que j'aurais ben je préfère partir à 64
plutôt qu'à 65 parce que ça me suffit
par rapport à mon niveau de vie je pense
qu'il faut aussi rendre la liberté aux
Français de pouvoir partir après l'âge
de départ légal en fonction de ce de
leur volonté surtout de leur niveau de
du pouvoir d'achat merci regardez une de
la Marseillaise aujourd'hui opération
vilmorte l’inter syndicale lance un
appel pour le 7 mars c'est à la Une de
La Marseillaise merci beaucoup Léo
purgate justement on va parler de ce 7
mars puisque effectivement l'Inter
syndical a redit à relancer un appel à
mettre la France à la règle que ça soit
la plus forte mobilisation depuis le
début de la contestation c'est en pleine
examen du texte au Sénat vous craignez
cette journée
craindre non je crains le durcissement
du conflit et de revoir des scènes de
prise en otage de Français qui veulent
se rendre au travail et qui pour des
raisons de grève de transport par
exemple le public ne peuvent pas ne
peuvent pas s'y rendre je pense qu'il y
a eu
les grands gagnants de cette séquence
pour moi ce sont les syndicats
aujourd'hui on s'est rendu compte que
les corps intermédiaires
pouvaient organiser des manifestations
sans pour autant faire des troubles
alors de public pouvait encadrer ces
manifestations ils ont fait preuve de
responsabilité notamment pendant les
vacances en disant bon on va pas
pénaliser les gens qui veulent partir en
vacances donc franchement il y a une
très bonne séquence des syndicats
attention durcissement du conflit je
pense que la CFDT
il n'y est pas étrangère à ce nouveau
dialogue qui peut qui peut s'instaur
avec avec les Français donc ce que je
crains plus c'est un mois de mars noir
parce que le fait de ne pas se faire
entendre on durci ces opérations et on
pénalise et l'ensemble des Français on
va parler de la question des grèves
justement puisque vous avez déposé une
proposition de loi pour rendre
impossible le droit de grève les
week-ends
[Musique]
les jours de grand départ on va en
parler dans le détail expliquez-nous
quels sont les grandes lignes alors le
contexte déjà et je vais commencer avec
une photo vous le voyez un homme avec un
bonnet de Père Noël nous sommes la
veille de Noël et c'est un grand-père
qui manifeste car selon lui il ne pourra
pas voir ses petits-enfants pour les
fêtes à cause des grèves de la SNCF
juste avant les fêtes de Noël on s'en
souvient c'est là qu'est né votre
proposition de loi Stéphane eurodulier
vous l'expliquez dans l'exposé des
motifs je vous cite aujourd'hui les
mobilisations syndicales et donc les
grèves ne sont plus suivies que par une
minorité de travailleurs prenons en
otage le reste de leur profession ainsi
que l'ensemble des Français vous
proposez donc avec le soutien d'une
quarantaine de vos collègues de rendre
impossible le droit de grève dans les
transports ferroviaires métro avion les
deux premiers jours et les deux derniers
jours des vacances scolaires pour
chacune des zones il vous proposait
aussi que ce soit le cas la veille et le
lendemain des jours fériés alors une
question le droit de grève c'est dans la
Constitution c'est aussi noter que le
législateur de l'encadrer mais là on
encadre pas on interdit pas du tout
c'est un encadrement vous avez le droit
de grève c'est effectivement c'est un
droit fondamental mais c'est pas un
droit absolu d'ailleurs vous l'avez
clairement précisé c'était au législatif
de l'encadrer oui cette proposition de
loi elle n'est d'une incompréhension
d'une certaine forme d'É
toujours sur 365 ça concerne des
jours-clés les chassés croisés de
vacances où on appelle à la
responsabilité je préférerais de
dialogue social avec les syndicats on
l'a vu dans le cadre de la réforme des
retraites mais pour éviter ce genre de
mouvement assez opaque qui paralyse
l'ensemble de la France je pense que le
législateur doit mieux encadrer le droit
de rêve
et
Bruno le président des républicains
votre président s'était en 2020 et
l'objectif c'était d'assurer un service
minimum les jours de grève alors ça a
été voté par le Sénat et puis ensuite ça
n'a pas été inscrit à l'ordre du jour à
l'Assemblée mais Bruno retailleux semble
y tenir un cas il en a reparlé sur votre
plateau Oriane c'était le 26 janvier à
écouter
je fais une proposition et je la mets
sur la table ce matin au gouvernement
j'ai fait voter il y a près de trois ans
un texte au Sénat sur un vrai service
public minimum c'était quoi c'était de
concentrer sur les heures de pointe de
la journée deux heures le matin 2h le
soir les jours ouvrés un tiers du trafic
quotidien là on peut à la fois concilier
le droit de grève et la continuité des
services publics et la liberté des gens
des Françaises et des Français d'aller
au travail
est-ce que votre proposition c'est une
manière de faire revivre cette
proposition qui avait été votée par le
Sénat si vous cumulez les deux
propositions vous avez un dispositif à
mon avis optimal pour pour les années à
venir effectivement moi j'appelle le
gouvernement à travailler avec les
organisations aussi syndicales pour
faire accepter le fait qu'il faut mieux
encadrer loin vous savez l'acceptabilité
d'un mouvement social c'est aussi pour
les Français c'est aussi le fait de ne
pas les pénaliser je pense que les
syndicats l'ont bien compris dans la
première phase de la réforme des
retraites j'espère et je j'espère qu'on
va reparler au mois de mars que le
durcissement du du conflit ne sera pas
de nouveau les écueils qu'on a qu'on a
pu vivre au mois de au mois de décembre
ou à dans d'autres vous avez 14
mouvements
sociaux en 20 ans pendant la période de
Noël au niveau de la SNCF c'est quand
même conséquent c'est des phénomènes qui
sont récurrents et qui exaspèrent la vie
des Français une petite question
d'agenda est-ce que votre proposition va
être inscrite dans la niche des
républicains
qui jugent de cela vous savez l'agenda
législatif est quand même assez assez
dense aussi
des priorités maintenant vous savez on
peut aussi fonctionner par amendement si
la PPL de Bruno Retailleau est inscrite
à l'Assemblée nationale pourquoi pas
faire un dispositif plus large et
intégré ce genre ce genre de disposition
législative dans la PPL Retailleau il y
a des discussions avec les LR à
l'assemblé justement sur le je ne sais
pas sur ce sur ce point je pourrais pas
vous dire
merci Audrey à tout à l'heure oui on va
parler de la France insoumise exactement
ce sera dans le club on va continuer à
parler des républicains puisque l'examen
de cette réforme de retraite n'a pas été
sans conséquence sur votre partie
Stéphane Rudy Aurélien Pradier de
vice-présidents exécutif samedi matin
est-ce que cette rencontre cette
décision pardon elle va pas à l'encontre
de la volonté de rassemblement prôné par
Éric
non je pense qu'il y a eu
de la part du président une marque
d'autorité qui était qui était
nécessaire
je pense que Aurélien Pradier a confondu
deux choses
code de popularité populaire la question
de fond qui posait est-ce que la la
droite s'est déconnecté du peuple à
perdu son côté populaire parce qu'on a
mené trois réformes sur les retraites je
ne le pense fondamentalement pas on a
perdu le peuple quand peut-être quand on
était au pouvoir en 2007 nous n'avons
pas clairement tenu l'ensemble des
engagements que nous avions pris
devant les Français et et être droites
c'est pas être moins à gauche que la
gauche c'est d'être ferme sur nos
convictions moi je me souviens d'un
Aurélien pragier qui prenait les 45 à
nuités
qui remettaient en cause années 67 ans
l'âge de départ avec le taux plein au
niveau de la retraite donc c'était 2019
qu'il a évolué sur ses convictions ça le
regarde mais encore une fois on a une
ligne politique qui avait été clairement
établi à travers un bureau politique où
on a eu quasi l'unanimité il y a 8
abstention dont est relié après il faut
faire preuve de cohérence de constance
et aussi d'unités même si on n'est pas
d'accord avec le vote démocratique d'un
bureau politique il y a une forme de
discipline à avoir au sein d'une famille
politique sauf que ça fait plusieurs
semaines qui tenaient ce discours est-ce
que c'était pas une erreur à ce
moment-là de l'avoir nommé à ce poste de
vice-président
à son poste de vice-président il n'avait
pas encore fait ses déclarations sur sur
les retraites à ce que je pour la
présidence il avait eu des déclaration
sur la réforme des retraites
c'était projet contre projet une fois
qu'Eric Ciot à remporté le congrat
interne je pense que c'est la ligne
ciottige à dire sur tir au Tayo puisque
sur ce sujet on était sur la même ligne
sur le même socle idéologique quand on
est à 80% des électeurs des républicains
qui pensent que le socle idéologique
c'est de travailler plus longtemps comme
on l'a toujours défendu vous savez ça
date pas d'aujourd'hui Nicolas Sarkozy
François Fillon
ont défendu ce genre de réforme donc
franchement je pense que c'était plus
par ambition personnelle pour une
visibilité médiatique que sur le fond
même de la réforme vous savez le seul
argument c'était les carrières longues
c'est un amendement les carrières
longues sur l'ensemble du texte il était
pas fondamentalement en plus en plus le
gouvernement a donné qui tue par rapport
à cela donc quel était le point
d'accroche qui lui permettait de voter
contre ce projet plus plus aucun donc
encore faire preuve de responsabilité
vous savez on peut être divers dans
notre famille politique la diversité ça
existe mais après il faut avoir
diversité et unités garder la cohérence
et la constance dans notre conviction
républicain c'est à lui dans juger s'il
considère il a encore sa place dans
votre partie on peut avoir des points
d'urgence si considère que c'est ces
convictions sont beaucoup trop éloignées
de la ligne politique du parti il doit
en tirer toutes les conséquences est-ce
que ça
est-ce que ça créerait une fracture au
sein des alors déjà dans le groupe à
l'Assemblée est-ce que là il y a un
risque d'un groupe ingérable
je pense qu'Olivier marlex fait preuve à
dépenser une énergie
assez assez importante durant ces
dernières semaines pour garder la
cohérence du groupe mais ce malaise là
il vient je vais vous dire d'un mal
beaucoup plus profond de notre famille
politique ça fait des années qu'on n'a
pas réfléchi sur notre socle idéologique
donc en fait on court derrière une ligne
politique en fonction des textes
présentés ou des projets de loi qui
arrivent du gouvernement il est grand
temps de refonder notre logiciel
idéologique de rendre la parole aux
militants sur les thèmes qui structure
un projet de société et derrière après
le vote de militants se ranger sur
chaque ligne politique actée par les
militants
il a compris d'ailleurs nommé pour la
refondation du projet je sais que Bruno
Retailleau
est une personne qui est très très
à même de d'aider aussi à cette
refondation des idées puisque ça lui
tient beaucoup beaucoup à cœur et que
c'est le sujet le sujet du moment un
dernier mot sur les républicains
puisqu'on a appris hier que le siège de
la région Auvergne Rhône-Alpes qui est
dirigé par Laurent Wauquiez a été
perquisitionné dans le cadre de
l'enquête ouverte par le parquet
national financier pour favoritisme et
détournement de fonds publics suite à un
coûteux dîner avec des personnalités
organisé l'été dernier par Laurent
Wauquiez est-ce qu'il est affaibli par
cette enquête
écoutez la justice suit son cours je
pense pas vous savez
Laurent Wauquiez a une stratégie
qu'il a mis en oeuvre on sait qu'il vise
pour vous c'est lui c'est votre candidat
il y a plus de débat maintenant au sein
du parti est-ce que le fait que Éric
Ciotti était élu en disant c'est Laurent
Wauquiez le candidat ça fait que vous
savez
moi je me méfie des pronostics à trois
ans ou à 4 ans
d'une échéance présidentielle je pense
que tout est ouvert Eric l'a clairement
dit Erick se t-il a clairement dit
c'était son candidat c'était sa
stratégie nous n’étons pas nous n'étions
pas sur la même ligne non pas par
rapport au candidats mais par rapport au
mode de sélection du candidat je pense
que ça se discutera aussi au sein de de
nos instances au sein du bureau
politique
pendant la campagne a dit que il fallait
qu'il soit désigné dès le début 2023 oui
mais je pense qu'il a évolué sur sur ce
sujet et c'était pas non plus le
calendrier de Laurent Wauquiez de ce que
j'avais de ce que j'avais compris ce qui
nous laisse le temps également on parle
de refondation du des idées après il y a
le celui qui va porter le projet il faut
pas mettre la charité la charrue mais
parlons des européennes la droite a une
responsabilité de porter un nouveau
projet européen et c'est dès maintenant
qu'on doit se mettre au travail on voit
avec les problèmes de souveraineté
souveraineté énergétique souveraineté
industriel souveraineté alimentaire tous
ces sujets doivent être mis sur la table
maintenant parce que les élections
européennes c'est dans un an un an que
ça commence juin 2024
il est le leader de notre famille
politique au sein du du PPE il a toute
sa place il est brillant et moi j'ai
confiance en lui pour justement il
apporte sa pierre à l'édifice et qui
puisse toiletter
notre projet européen parce que les
Français attendent beaucoup de cela
merci Stéphanie merci beaucoup d'avoir
été entre la semaine prochaine on débat
jour du début de la réforme des
retraites je reviendrai sur ce plateau
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
dans le club de territoire on viendra
sur cette visite d'Emmanuel Macron hier
matin l'aube pour parler travail réforme
des retraites pouvoir d'achat ce sera à
suivre dans le club d'abord on a quand
même notre chaîne invité manuel Bompard